The Joe Rogan Experience now I could go
back to like my roots of being just a
white trash [__]
it's nice man I'm really accepted who I
am you know well it's it's so
interesting to watch people go through
these changes in life in these trials
through adversity and become like a very
interesting person at the end of it oh
you know like I I you know I know you
say a lot of outrageous [__] and it's
very funny but you also say some very
good [__] you know like this speech that
you gave when you're talking about
America like the that speech the
post-fight press conference speech it's
a [__] great speech well do you know
it is you man I I'm white trash like I
like what I mean by that is like I am
the future of America so like like
both my parents work you know my dad's
piece [__] but you know [__] in Hell
probably right now but both my parents
worked they made good money but we were
poor we were poor because after the
cigarettes the bars and the fast food
were [__] poor I mean like you know
we had like [__] well I can't tell
you you'd find a piece of paper and you
wrinkled up you use that [__] toilet
paper you know type of times I wipe my
ass with a with a piece of [__] paper
you get laying around
but this is like it's like this Unholy
Alliance that corporations are doing to
America they want women working they
want lower wages and they want more
consumerism and it's like I don't mean
it like I'm not sexist like oh put woman
back in the kitchen you know they suck
and I love [__] women you know take
off the burger wear a [__] bikini and
huzzah but
but you know what I'm saying but we're
truly like in a weird time to where like
corporations are eroding eroding values
of America well they act within their
best interests in their best interests
to keep people consumers and make sure
that people just pay attention only to
stupid [__] you you have Walmart in the
in the in your phone now you want to go
I mean I can't even me I'm to blame
there's some times you guys where I'm
like man I'm a little depressed I don't
know I [__] it's in a bad mood I'm
like I'm gonna go on Amazon let's see
what the [__] Amazon fairy is
recommending me today maybe I could
maybe I could find something they'll
give me a little serotonin boost find
some happiness in a one click yeah and
then so it's like you and then you have
like and then on top of that now we go
full circle you have two parents working
and I'm going the mostly on the west
coast you have shitty [__] kids dude
Las Vegas graduation where it's less
than 50 High School Dropout no GED I'm
not one to talk
but how do you raise how do you raise a
family a successful family when your
kids are being raised by the system
right by [__] Tick Tock after my
fight I had the doctor you know good
good guy the doctor UFC he comes up to
me he's like hey why are you why are you
talking bad about Las Vegas I'm like
well Dr John or your name is Doctor
equal dude what what school do your kids
go to and he just like gets a big like
smirk I'm like yeah I'm sure you're
paying like 50 50 plus a year right
educate your kids like so again man I
mean where's the reset button maybe
there is no reset button I think the
reset button is teaching people that
there's things that you can do in life
that can transform you and I think as
weird as that sounds a lot of people
learn that through watching people like
you evolve through fighting because it's
the most difficult thing you do outside
of war and being a cop and being a
fireman
it's the most difficult physical Pursuit
that a person can get involved with for
a living but again we're talking on such
a deeper fundamental level if you have
no belief like we could say America is
becoming atheist
like we could say that if you have no
belief if you have no moral right no
wrong right and you're not taught this
from like a stable family and you're
being raised I mean like literally
America is becoming like communist China
where like we're letting our school
system dictate values and believe we're
letting the system tell you what your
kids are and again I'm agnostic so I'm
not I'm not telling everybody to go find
Jesus you know if you're going to find
somebody at least let it be [__]
Jesus right but uh I mean how do you how
do you fix a moral decay of a society
when
that's just where we're going you've got
Tick Tock man even even [__]
communist China will will mitigate what
shows on Tick Tock but they give us
other [__] filth but it's just uh I
know exactly what you're saying and I
you know I went through the public
school system but I did it in the 1980s
that's very different getting worse yeah
it's a lot worse now but I mean how do
you like again like if you were you know
if you were God Joe Rogan how do you fix
this you gotta you gotta pump a lot of
money into inner cities you gotta you
gotta figure out a way to make programs
and there's there's places in this
country that for decades and decades
have been filled with crime and gang
violence and drug addiction and that's
all they know and that's that's the
standard of their community and that's
what you grow up with and that's what
you see and if and if we don't fix that
the odds of those people coming out of
there I mean there's a few that come out
of there that become you know whether
they're artists or athletes or whatever
it is they find a way through they
figure it out but they're the rare ones
okay they're the rare ones which we've
got to do is create systems where you
have opportunity for kids and also
mitigate the crime and mitigate the
violence and and whatever the [__] has
to be done look if they can dump
billions of dollars into Ukraine his
[__] aim if they could dump billions
of dollars into I mean there's so many
different things that they they pump
money into but they've never pumped any
money into Baltimore they never pumped
any money into Detroit like try to
figure out a way like if you can like
think about like what Halliburton did
during the Iraq War they got these no
bid contracts where Cheney was the
[__] CEO of Halliburton he becomes
the vice president of the United States
and then the company he worked for gets
these no bid contracts to rebuild [__]
we blow up
which is wild but there's profit in that
right so what about figuring out a way
to funnel that profit into fixing inner
cities yeah if we have less losers we
have a better America and if you give
people more opportunity you have less
losers you know so even let let's go on
the smallest scale of sex like uh how
old are you Joe 55. when did when's the
first time you started watching pork I
asked that question yeah it was uh VHS
tapes came out when I was like I
probably was like 15 15 or 16. okay so I
mean we had uh my brother so my brother
is a few years older than me so he
remembers things that I don't but he'll
like tell me I mean like I'm like oh
[__] I forgot about that so I was
watching porn and like early Elementary
School like first grade and second grade
like because we had like a communal porn
box oh yeah yeah like my dad my dad my
dad had this like an old school water
heater box and just stacked with [__]
porn right
so you kids don't know about this but we
had like the communal VCR so like you
would go to you would go to watch
Aladdin you know and all of a sudden
like buttfuckers 29 is on the yeah TV so
I started watching porn when I was like
I don't know I was jerking off to the
[__] third grade dude my [__]
third grade teacher but like but I was
surrounded by that right right so so I'm
already I'm at this moral Decay and it
was like and I was the odd one I was the
odd one man like I had to go [__]
find the porn I had to go [__] my
brother always jokes my brother always
jokes that like when he would like take
my dad's porn tape out of the VCR he'd
always have to rewind it to where he
started so no one knew he was watching
porn with any jokes said oh man I always
know where my dad's coming now
[Music]
thing up
gross but so yeah right [__] hey
Eddie my dad was [__] I'm surprised
I'm not more [__] up but you know so
what I'm saying is he alive now no he
died of cancer is actually [__] yeah
I [__] get on I'll tell you but it
was it's kind of funny um
like so I'm an oddity I'm an audience
I'm jerking off I'm a little [__] kid
you know I'm an oddity like I'm I'm
[__] violent but now but now dude you
give a little kid a cell phone
and you have two parents working next
thing you know I mean you [__] go on
Instagram you got titties in your face
like now we're like hyper sexualizing
kids and I I think that's also a big
moral Decay because the moment you
become hypersexualized and I can't stop
thinking about [__] [__] and dick
like right it starts [__] your brain
up at such a young age and it's a very
unusual way to give it to kids where
they have instant access to watching
porn on their phone yeah and then and we
have no morals there's no there's no
reason not to be a shitty person these
days you ain't going to heaven just
[__] go [__] [__] the chick
commenter like you don't gotta raise
your [__] kid so I think one of the
best things we can do as Society is
mitigate mitigate sex because that is
like the gateway to like that's why we
want to make money that's why kids want
to sell drugs that's why kids want to go
[__] party there is no [__] [__]
like you know no one no one [__] like
no one if like if there is no [__]
[__] no one's going to a party like
whatever why don't go to a party and
drink I'm gonna go to get [__] [__]
you know right yeah I always joke I say
no one shoots up a school because they
have too much [__] [__] that's true
but there are some good things about it
there are some good things about it oh
for sure there's good things about it
but it is weird when it's like
hyper-sexualizing kids but it's not good
and then like you go and you see [__]
kids these days like the [__] they wear
like [__] dude put some [__]
clothes on you [__] like 16 your
[__] titties are out well they're
being told that that's what gets them
attention yes you know and they're being
they see it all the time on Instagram
when a girl has like five million
followers and every photo is a picture
of her [__] hanging out and [__] you
know I'm [__] dude oh it's crazy yeah
Norman nor McDonald I loved him I
[__] love Norman he's a great guy man
I love this skit about like being famous
he's like what do we have to do after
they went to the moon you know like you
had to go the moon to be famous now you
just show your [__] [__]
success dude [__] there we go man